[Music]
andrea is with us in san diego hi andrea
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure um
okay so my dad died uh 37 years ago and
my mom started he left uh properties and
assets so my mom um we're three kids
now in the age of 50 around 50. um so my
mom started managing um
the properties then did she not did your
mom own them at that time
um when your dad died did he leave all
the property to your mom
uh
okay we're talking about six properties
two are jointly owned with my brothers
my mom um in argentina when the spouse
dies 50
is for it's complicated dave 50 uh to my
mom and the the other 50 belongs to the
three of us two properties are like that
okay and then two were in an llc um
which are
about to be
um
put in a title for my brothers my two
brothers
they live in argentina i live here in
the us right so
the properties are in argentina
correct okay
so
uh okay so my mother started managing
them first then my youngest brother
started managing and putting most of the
money in his pocket
then in one of my trips
that was raised to me by my
middle brother
and they both started managing
the properties
pocketing most of the money themselves
right i was just getting um whatever
they they thought was fair
um now that years have passed i have
grown children i started looking into
numbers and things like that and i'm
realizing that they have been giving me
between 55 um 15 and 25 percent of what
was supposed to
uh my part right um
so i would like i'm trying to divide
things to make things clear transparent
um but they are reluctant they are
lashing out
one has completely shut down he doesn't
take my phone calls
and um
so
and my mom
i mean in a way she's a little bit
biased right i mean she loves the three
of us but in a way she's a little bit
biased because she's chauvinistic you
know that's the way she was raised yeah
i'll tell you what you hang on when we
come back from this break we'll hear the
rest of this sordid story we're talking
with andrea in san diego she's got
brother sisters brothers and her mother
uh with managing inherited property that
she's a partial owner of in argentina
they've been paying her what they wanted
to pay her over the years and she just
looked up the other day decided to do
some math after 36 years and discovered
that she's not getting her fair share
now she's trying to separate this and
get clarity on it and she's getting a
lot of pushback is that a fair summary
of what you told us so far andrea
yes
okay so what are you going to do
that's my question to you uh and also uh
let's add that they have lived rent free
for one at least 18 years and the other
one seven years rent free plus receiving
all the income from the other properties
right yeah and my mom insists on me
being nice andrea be nice be nice to
them
be nice
means not telling them i mean i i am
frustrated being nice means getting
screwed by your brothers
in a way yes no definitely they've been
screwing you over for years is what you
just told us
decades yes they've been messing you
over for a long time and that's her
definition of being nice no thanks mom
i'll pass on being nice
it's not being nice that's being a
victim
i don't want to be a victim well you are
a victim but you you know and if you're
going to con either going to continue to
be one or you're not it's up to you
so you've got a couple of options here
as far as actually three
one
you just keep going like you are
and be nice
yeah no okay
the other one is you can just uh sign
over all the property to them
and say good luck with it boys i'm done
with y'all i don't want any more money i
don't want anything else to do with any
of you you've messed me over so bad
here's the deed to everything i'm just
going to walk away from this the family
dysfunction is not worth whatever the
assets are i'm through with you and just
sign it over to him which by the way is
not a really bad idea
that's not a bad idea at all it's not
the idea you were expecting me to give
you
and of course the third option is to use
the argentine in courts
to settle this
if your brothers don't come to the table
peacefully and start signing over
properties to you
yeah
i think they're blind they're blind by
rage and fear i don't care um
yeah
you get they they have 10 days
or they have 30 days from the time i
call them
regardless of all their screwed up
dysfunctions and machoism or whatever it
is they're dealing with
to you have 30 days for us to work this
out if you do not work this out by this
date
my attorney will begin the process in
the argentinian courts of suing all of
your pants off
okay and by the way the attorneys are
going to get all the money and the
family's going to end up with nothing
that's how this always works because
that's how attorneys work
yes so andrea what was the agreement up
front 36 37 years ago that you would get
a third
i was uh when my dad died i was 14 years
old i was a kid so
i mean i had no agreement right
now there was a will there was a there
was a direction
between the estate was supposed to be
no there was no will uh we were talking
about six properties two were in an llc
two were
in our name jointly on my two brothers
and i so two are like that and two are
in a succession right
uh they're supposed to be
uh in our name i mean 50 for my mom and
50 for three of us
and you said you're getting about 15 to
20 what would you think would be fair
what is the mathematically correct
amount to get
a year
well percentage-wise you said you're
getting 15 to 20 you're saying you
should be getting 33.
i'm i'm saying 15 20 uh 25 percent of
the
33 that i should get yeah you gotta you
got you got a a tiny fraction of what
you should be getting right
right so here's the thing
they you have lost trust in them
because they've stolen from you
yes and so you either need to walk away
from them
or you need to separate the properties
and if they don't do that
uh
with reasonableness and voluntarily will
have a judge make them do that
okay
i don't know anything about argentine
and law or courts
in the u.s this is a partnership a
general partnership that you're going
before civil court and asking the judge
to force the disillusionment of the
partnership which means they either buy
you out or they sell the property and
everybody gets their section everybody
gets their part
okay force the disillusionment of the
partnership because you no longer trust
your partners who sadly are your own
brothers
funded emotionally by your mother who is
an enabler
yes yes
yes
yeah and so it's a sad thing i'm so
sorry it breaks your heart and honestly
i i don't know what is your financial
situation how wealthy are you
i'm doing well what would as well you
got 10 million dollars or two dollars no
no no no no no uh in about less than 10
years we're going to pay off my house in
san diego california and we have another
if you never got another dime from this
would it really affect your life
no
not really but
um
i mean i feel i'm not standing up for my
own family at this point i know you're
not uh i know you're not but let me just
tell you
i don't think you're going to fix your
family
i think when this is all said and done
they're all still going to be pissed
don't you
probably yeah so you're not going to get
there
there's not going to be a there's not a
version of this story where everybody
gets together and smiles
and makes a big meal and is so glad to
see each other again
there's that version of this story does
not exist
that's not going to happen is it
if you talk them into it and they did
you your portion you're still going to
feel badly towards them for stealing
from you and they're still going to feel
like you force them into doing something
they didn't want to do if you sue them
we know that they're going to feel that
way and your no you're going to feel
that way and now everybody's writing
lawyers checks too
so it's there's not a version of this
story where everybody gets back together
and is all happy again
yeah too much misbehavior under the
bridge
i wish it would happen but i don't think
it's going to happen realistically so
you've just got to decide what you want
to do i think you need to seriously
consider
from from your standpoint
uh the idea of just deeding it over to
them
and just walking away
i don't want to do that okay all right
then you gotta fight then then you're
going to you're getting ready stir up a
ruckus kiddo
that's not an argentina phrase that's a
hillbilly phrase you're gonna you're
gonna stir up a ruckus i don't know how
you say that in spanish but you're about
to start i'd love to hear it it'd
probably sound really cool
but this whole thing is just dripping
with resentment on either side and so
everybody's mad and hurt it's just
poisoning yourself at some point and
there's a little sleep at night there's
a lot of times in these situations and
it because even her giving him them the
property is not going to make them happy
or her happy
there's not a version not an option that
i see on the table where everyone plays
patty cake and kissy face after this is
done
they're just not going to this has gone
on too long mom is too screwed up the
brothers are too big of crooks and she's
too pissed about it yeah and you're
talking international and so there's not
you can't just [ __ ] it's international
pissed this is a different level
different level
i'm not messing with argentina man
this is a tough situation she's going to
have to get a backbone here and so
regardless of
the country this illustrates why you
need a will
and why you need to read the will while
you're alive
and tell everyone what's going to happen
if everybody's going to be mad after
you're gone go ahead do it while you're
live just make them mad now
go ahead and show them now this is
what's going to happen
you're doing cocaine so we're leaving
you nothing okay and you can just be
pissed about that now okay go ahead and
be mad about it or you're dysfunctional
and you're disconnected from the family
and so we're not leaving you anything
let's go ahead and clear the air on that
when i pass if i'm the dad what i don't
want is for my kids to bicker and fight
for the rest of their lives because of
what i left them as a blessing each of
them arguing incorrectly what dad's will
was when he had a will we all have our
own interpretation no yeah daddy always
said i don't give let me tell you what
daddy always said daddy always read the
will once a year and said this is what
it is baby mama always said this is what
it is baby you need to have a reading of
the will while you're alive
to be why they call it a will what is my
will
upon my death my will for you is that
you get this and you get this that's
what the will means we say to be unclear
is to be unkind and this is
testament your testament as to what you
want to have happen we'll go ahead and
cover it while you're alive and write it
down in a legal document and everyone
then is on the same page